hey guys today we're bringing you a new
car from the boom state project and own
use of stone expansion hi i'm super viz
and I'm Lambie series we have our team
researchers from Singapore boom state
projects an all-new expansion from Huff
stone featuring current artifact new
cuts that will be released on August 7
today cut review is the nekron blade do
you want to take a guess what cutting is
okay so it kind of looks a bit like
weapon with some fluids inside I mean I
guess it looks like it's gonna give
poisonous to something I mean yeah what
comes do you think it is I mean it's a
dagger I'm pretty sure the dagger so I
guess it's gonna be rope okay you're
kind of half right on it okay the
neckroll a is a rope cut that costume on
arm with sri attack and to durability
its effect is the director that triggers
the diverter of our random friendly
minions all right okay so from just
looking at the cut it has the same stage
with the fiery war axe like force now I
think quite a bit of value seeing that
again you can attack twice and it's do
can trigger the direct of any minion
about random on the board so um
just going a little bit like what
definitely minions do you think would
would trigger with this would be working
with this one I guess it's similar to
play this by using a weapon form so you
can trigger in like you all right envy
like that ever saw it I never saw a
great right okay um the funny thing
about this is that I just realized also
that it since it's a rock weapon right
the thing is it's very hard to counter
because like even let's say your hero
gets frozen you can just read agar with
your hero power and you get a desultory
effect oh yeah the decoration still she
goes
okay so now that we've seen the cut
let's go into some synergies of the cut
which will be very useful for a coming
master okay the facility there can't
involve is in a temple okay where the
weapon can walk be for demo sorry
whatever so it can be popped when the
weapon heat on the minion and then you
get a 5/5 will give you a bit tempo
swing
since we're on the topic of never saw
eggs and weapon braking and stuff
actually thinking of something along the
lines of universe cube and charge Manila
yes lady Roy yeah like Leroy so
basically what I'm thinking of right now
is like if you cube the Leroy and you
keep the pace with the weapon that's
right it triggers the kind of rescue
yeah correct and then you get tons of
damage I mean it's Leroy for six and
then there is a sumo Leroy's from the
canaries cube that's another six and six
and then after it this is the weapon
damage it's about 21 de Mayo with the
cube still intact and to Molly right in
the
container and since be on the topic of
one-time kills oh my gosh let me tell
you about another one I've just thought
about es go oh wow okay let's say you
know you guys know as Mele goes right
okay so that this cat its COBOL
illusionists what happens is when
coalition is is destroyed when it dies
it actually spawns a 1:1 copy of a
minion from your hand so what actually
happens if the macroblade is when you
attack with an extra play and it gets
destroyed and
belly goes from your hand and you guys
all know what many goes does you got
that's plus 5 spell damage to all spells
in your head so if you do the math right
guys let's do the quick math together so
if we do one sinister strike plus one
sinister strike plus eviscerate plus
another eviscerate that is actually 34
damage and it actually fits in with your
vehicle roll over you know Molly Molly
oh yeah and there's actually like 10
mana so it's a kind of a perfect Oh Tiki
I'm very curious if you guys would be
able to pull it off I know it's kind of
a lot of cards but kind of amazing
amazing
so I think the best way to counter is
fov either to clear the ball of death
metal media or we could silence death
metal media or maybe setback the Deaf at
Dominion so I'm not able to let the
weapon activate for the Deaf writer so
what are the things that you can think
yeah I do agree that keeping the bot
clear and preventing the death toll from
the weapons of war is one of the best
ways to neuter the effects of the weapon
also actually technically if you do
freeze the enemy hero right you cannot
attack the weapon and technically they
wouldn't be able to trigger their friend
however we have to remember that this is
a rock class here what does the rock
have it has its own dagger so what
happens is you can actually just be
dagger to get the death metal off so
it's a quite an interesting interaction
with Holly happens so very interested to
see what you guys can do with this guy
Tom Dexter can thing almost like
temporal we fly a fighter like Lou Hodel
or Cambridge with the weapon can walk
with which gives you a lot important
terms like the attempt or opponent yeah
I guess he was like a good day before
maybe you will be a better day after the
expansion okay uh also what neck do is
anything off right of course I do agree
that temporal might have a resurgence
okay so uh I'm very curious to see what
kind of more decks people can make I
mean abusing Debra those has always been
a thing if you guys remember tannaz off
you know I miss that cat so yeah uh of
the time I mentioned many goes so I
really really am curious to see what you
guys
once the booms the project expansion
jobs knocking to claim three cutbacks
and a random class legendary both from
the new expansion for free alright guys
there are also two pre-order bundles for
purchase the first bundle costs $49.99
US dollars and it includes 50 the books
they project packs one random golden the
booms their project legendary card and
the mecha jaraxxus cutbacks there's also
a mega bundle which constantly $9.99 US
dollars this includes a new warlock hero
to add to your collection make art
directors elder law of the mega bundle
all right and both bundles are available
for purchase now but you get your cart
back can only be open on the 7th of
August
[Music]